Oh
[Music]
my name is Kade Ishida I am a data
engineer at line cooperation this year
we created a webpage that analysis
platform named Oasis all of our
company's employees can analyze data of
our Hadoop cluster as they like by
writing spirk applications now more than
100 employees use this platform every
day in this talk I'm going to describe
the details of this platform my talk is
composed of these three topics first I'm
going to explain why we decided to
create a basis next I'd like to describe
its features in system architecture in
detail last way I'll introduce its use
cases at line so let's move on to the
first topic why we decided to create a
basis first of all let me introduce my
company line cooperation line is a
communication platform provider based in
Tokyo Japan and its main product line is
the number one messaging application in
Asia line has about 164 million monthly
active users across Japan Thailand
Taiwan and Indonesia as well as having
more outside of these men were kids we
also provide various services related to
line such as games a sticker market news
music video streaming a payment platform
and advertisement platform and so on
we have a centralized Hadoop cluster to
manage and analyze each services data
there are hype databases in the Hadoop
cluster and each database contains
different services data for example the
line game database stores only line
games data and the sticker market
database contains only sticker market
data and so on this data is processed by
atl batch processing and analyzed by
these scientists or visualized on BI
tools such as IBM Cognos or tableau at
the end of last year we started a new
project to make our Hadoop Hadoop
cluster public within our company
that means each employee can access our
Hadoop clusters data directly and
analyze their services data as they like
this was necessary for all our employees
to speed up their data analysis process
and decision making here are the
requirements of our new debt analysis
platform first we have to control each
employee's data access strictly each
employee should only be able to access
the data related to their service they
must not be able to access the other
services data secondly we have to make
our new debt analysis platform stable
data analysis processing and queries
must continue to work normally even if
other users submit heavy queries or
applications the last requirement is
about features each employee can extract
data from our Hadoop cluster as they
like by writing Furies or applications
so result can be visualized and shared
within a team or a department these were
the main requirements regarding our new
data analysis platform here are the
solutions that we came up with for
controlling each employees data access
strictly we introduced Kerberos
authentication to our Hadoop cluster and
we used Apache Ranger for authorization
Apache Ranger is a framework to manage
data access control over a Hadoop
cluster we have a hive database for each
line service so we control who can exist
which hive database by Apache Ranger for
stability we decided to use Apache spirk
as a Curie and an application execution
engine because spoke applications can
run as a young application on our Hadoop
Ian cluster that means we can delegate
resource control to our young resource
manager and we also decided to use
Apache the plane as a user interface
Apache deplane is a web-based data
analysis tool its supports Apache spurt
and user impersonation extracted data
can be visualized as multiple charts and
the result can be shared with other
users these features seem to meet our
requirements so we decided to use Apache
pain as a user interface for our new
data analysis platform this is the
system architecture of our first data
analysis platform each user accesses
Apache a plane and writes program
location code on it
and it submits a spirk application to
our Hadoop cluster while impersonating
the end users account the spork
application running on the UM cluster
accesses HDFS data with the end users
account and Apache ranger checks if the
account can actually access the data or
not the application result is returned
to Apaches airplane which is visualized
in a formal Church and its share with
the end users team members we operated
this data analysis platform for several
months and we noticed that Apache the
plane did not match our requirements in
some respects the first issue was about
security
Apache zipping has a scheduling feature
that can execute a spoke application on
a prescribed date on time automatically
users can set another user account to
the user of this scheduled execution so
by exploiting this defect users can
access the data which they don't have
access rights to Apache Ranger the
second issue was about stability Apache
the plane runs only on a single server
and version zero point seven point three
does not support your own cluster mode
of Apaches burg so all truck driver
programs and Apaches obtain process run
on the same server and it freezes if one
of driver programs consumes too many
server resources that means we could not
operate Apache server instability due to
this issue
some Apache Zeppelin features did not
match our requirements for example users
can share a notebook with other users
but they have to set access control to
each notebook as the number of users and
the number of notebooks increase the end
users operation and notebook management
cost increase in addition in my
company's use case it was needed to
execute a previously created notebook
while changing its parameters without
saving it however we could not do such a
thing
Apaches airplane so due to these issues
we could not use Apaches airplane as a
user interface for our new data analysis
platform so we created our own user
interface named oasis we we have
developed it referencing Apaches
airplane but we also added some features
to it to solve the a participant issues
as I talked about earlier in particular
users cannot submit an arbitrary spirk
application by using other users account
and Oasis can run on multiple servers so
that it can handle an increase in the
number of users and notebooks we have
been operating overseas for about six
months and now more than 100 users use
it every day to wrap up the first topic
I'd like to explain the difference
between Apaches airplane and Oasis
Apaches airplane is a good solution for
a single team because it doesn't go with
Apache Ranger it runs only on a single
server and users have to set access
control to each notebook on the other
hand always this is for an enterprise
that means it can be used for multiple
teams or departments because it works
well with Apache Ranger
it runs on multiple servers and notebook
access control is set per team not per
notebook we had to create our new data
analysis platform for many teams or
departments and Apache Zeppelin did not
match our requirements because it was
aimed at a single team so we created
always this as a user interface for
enterprise use so far I've explained our
motivation for creating oasis next I'd
like to describe its features and system
architecture this is the overview of
Oasis main features users can extract
data from our Hadoop cluster as they
like by writing spoke applications when
a sperg application accesses HDFS data
its writers account is used by Apache
spurts user impersonation feature so
that the data access is controlled by
Apache Ranger extractive data can be
visualized in the form of a table a bar
chart or a line shirt multiple
visualization results can be bundled
into a notebook and notebooks can be
shared within a team or a department
always can run on multiple servers so
that it can handle an increase in the
number of users and notebooks now I'd
like to look at its features in detail
this is a screenshot of the top page
line services teams and departments are
listed on this page in Oasis each
service or team is called as
a single space also represents a root
directory of notebooks access right for
each user is separate or a set in each
space there are two types of access
rights read write and read only this
slide shows an example there are two
spaces space one and space - in space
one there are two users user a has
readwrite access and user behaves will
only exist
similarly in space - users see has
readwrite access and user D has
read-only access in this situation is a
a can read and create notebooks in space
one whereas user B can read notebooks
but cannot create a notebook in that
space in addition they cannot access
notebooks in space - so in erases
notebook access control is set per space
not per notebook and that gets rid of in
the user's notebook management costs
this is a screenshot of a notable
creation page users can right sprocket
potential sprocket allocation code
submit it to a Hadoop cluster and
visualize the result in the form of a
table a bar chart or a line chart a
notebook can contain multiple sprach
application code and their visualization
results notebooks can be shared within a
team or a department
ass perk up Legation launches per
notification that means as perk
application starts when a user opens a
notebook creation page and it stops when
they save or close the notable creation
page when a spray application accesses
HDFS data note books authors user
account is used by Apaches perks user
impersonation feature spork spork sequel
PI's perk and spur curve are supported
on Oasis and they share a single spore
complication that means
dead-set can be shared within these
different programming languages here is
an example there are three pieces of
spork application code on the notebook
the one on the left is writtings scholar
and it generates data frames and
temporary views so one in the middle is
within PI's perk it gets data from the
temporary views and draws a scatter
diagram with matplotlib the one on the
right is between sprach sequel it also
extracts data from one of the temporary
views and visualizes the result in the
form of a table in this way this set can
be shared within different programming
languages by using Oasis's spoke
application sharing feature in addition
OSE sees proxy ql interpreter takes
advantage of Apaches perks dead set
caching feature a query result can be
cached in spoke Victor's memories and
other queries can access it this slide
shows an example the query on the Left
extracts data from a table and caches
the result in spirk existence memories
the other two queries exist the cached
data and visualize the result in the
form of a line shirt and a broadchurch
respectively like this this set can be
shared within different programming
languages oh sorry
query result can be cached and other
crews can access it this feature is
useful where multiple queries access the
same data set because it's much faster
to access cache data then extract data
from an actual table Oasis has a
notebook scheduling feature that can
execute a notebook on a priest
automatically on a prescribed data on
time contents of an order which can be
kept up to date by using this feature
and this feature can also be used for
implementing ETL processing outline
many users implement they are did their
own data pre-processing program by
writings spoke or liseberg code such ETL
processing can be implemented and
schedule parameter input forms can be
put into a notebook while creating it
parameters can be injected into each
section of code of a notebook during its
execution this feature enables read-only
users to execute a notebook while
changing its parameters when they do it
Oasis has some features to manipulate
hive databases and tables it has a
feature to list hive databases and
tables and show each table schema so
users can check such information while
writing queries or SPRO complications
and users can create hive tables by
uploading a CS
or TSV file to Oasis and and they can
easily analyze data files on their local
machines by uploading them and creating
hive tables this is the system
architecture of Oasis front-end and API
servers handle and the users requests
when a user submits spirk application
code one of the front-end and API
servers receives it and transfers it to
one of the spoke interpreter service
after that the spoke interpreter server
submits a spoke application to the
Hadoop UN cluster and the spoke
application running on the current
cluster accesses HDFS data whose data
access is controlled by Apache Ranger
the application result is saved
temporarily on Redis and it's returned
to the end-users web browser when a user
saves a notebook its contents will be
saved permanently on my sequel if an
execution schedule is set to a notebook
it will be registered and managed on
oasis Java scheduler servers each Oasis
component such as front-end API
JavaScript interpreter can run on
multiple servers so that Oasis can
handle an increase in the number of
users and notebooks this is the summary
of our centralized Hadoop cluster we
have five hundred data nodes and node
managers there are approximately 20
petabytes of data on HDFS we have more
than 150 hive databases and 1500 hive
tables
that covers the main features and system
architecture of Oasis moving on to the
next part let me talk about its use
cases at y this is the statistics of
Oasis in my company we have more than
1500 total users 100 daily active users
and 300 monthly active users there are
more than 30 spaces that means over 30
departments teams or services use Oasis
in my company we have around 1100
notebooks among them approximately 200
notebooks are executed automatically on
their predefined schedules our use cases
of Oasis can be roughly classified into
these five categories I'll show you an
example notebook for each each case the
first use case is a report users can use
a notebook as a report that shows
numbers or indices about a product or
service in the form of a table or chart
contents of a report can be kept up to
date by setting it executes
automatically by using Oasis scheduling
feature so users can always view the
latest report quickly without executing
any queries or applications the second
use case is an interactive dashboard as
I said earlier parameters can be
injected into a notebook by using this
feature users can change parameters such
as timespan and read all the content of
a note work
this feature is useful for read-only
users because they can easily explore
data as they like by changing parameters
of a notebook which has already been
created even if they don't have the
skills to write queries or spraga
applications the third one is ETL
processing users can implement their own
data pre-processing program by writing
spark or PI spark called on a notebook
and setting it executes automatically at
wine users create many ETL notebooks for
pre-processing and cleansing data so
that they can analyze data quickly and
efficiently on Oasis the next case is
monitoring some of our users create a
notebook that is executed automatically
and periodically such as hourly and
daily to validate a part of data on our
Hadoop cluster in this example this
notebook is executed hourly and
visualizes the hourly number of certain
log data in the form of a time series
series chart and if there is is a
significant change in the data pattern
users can receive notification so always
this is used for data monitoring and a
kind of outlier detector in my company
the last use case is ad hoc data
analysis Oasis supports PI spark and pro
card as well as some dead scientists
analyzing data by using them to
visualize the result with matplotlib in
Python or ggplot2 in or and they also
give the data analysis code a test run
on Oasis beef
or they deploy it to the production
environment so that's all I have to say
about about our use cases of aces in
closing my presentation I'd like to go
over the key points we created Oasis
which is a data analysis platform for
enterprise use to solve the security and
stability issues we have with Apache
deplane users can submit work
applications to extract and process data
from our Hadoop cluster as well as
visualize the result on a basis by
taking advantage of Apaches perks user
impersonation feature each end users
account is used when they access HDFS
data so that their data access is
controlled properly and strictly by
Apache Ranger apply Oasis is used to
create reports build interactive
dashboards run ETL processing monitor
data and perform ad hoc data analysis
that's all for my presentation thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you I have two questions the first
one have you considered Jupiter I
checked some other tools such as Jupiter
or reddish but none of them met our
requirements for example Jupiter doesn't
have a feature to easily visualize the
query result in form of a chart so we
have many people many employees who can
write only queries so to give their the
ability to visualize it Ariza
visualizations Jupiter cannot be used
for our use case okay I think is the
second question is is it open source not
yet but we wish but we now have many
enhancements request from our employees
so when when we finish that we will
prepare for making it public
yes
hello so can you explain more about like
what kind of mr. that use OS is like
hundred active user daily like you mean
like most of them are engineer or data
scientists all like there are some
rory's of our employees such as
engineers and directors or product
managers or machine learning engineers
or dead scientists but mainly directors
who watch kpi's of a product they are
the main users so say that even an
engineer work at lie will I be able to
excel
Oh Asus yes engineers can also used for
running for running code to visualize or
analyze data okay thank you
you